this is turn the page tuesday the teams
we start with all the positives now we
get to the teams that need to flip it
carolina panthers really good start to
the year for them winning a bunch of
games with coach roll sam darnold
leaving the jets going down there to the
panthers loose to the cowboys though who
are a talented team like we just hit on
what's the page that they need to turn
there in carolina
carol hey carolina panthers came in as
the number one defense in league but
they really hadn't seen an offense like
the cowboys dak prescott you think about
zeke and tony pollard over 200 yards dak
prescott wasn't even sacked i thought
like we talked about before the
offensive players did uh the offensive
line did a heck of a job the panthers
are a good young team they have a good
young defense jeremy chin he's going to
be an outstanding young safety but he
had a rough day against the cowboys and
i like what matt rule is doing down
there he's got everything guys buying
into it he's very organized and these
guys compete so
this is one of those teams just like the
the las vegas raiders those teams are
going to be very competitive here in the
future
a couple guys i want to hit on there
caroline it's always tough for them to
play without christian mccaffrey
mccaffrey's missed some games he's one
of those guys that he did if you go back
to stanford he missed a lot of games
when he's on the field it's unbelievable
and a lot of times he's not on the field
that's the one downfall to that somebody
else though dj moore who was a first
round pick back in 2018 out of maryland
and i've been critical of carolina in
terms of when they had cam newton they
really weren't giving him good weaponry
to work with like you know greg olson
was his number one and olson battled
injuries but there was never somebody on
the outside you really worried about and
now we're seeing dj moore become that
and if he can become that i think sam
darnold's going to have an awesome year
and there's one other player that i
really like down there who's tommy
tremble and i'll just give you him as
one to to just keep a side eye on as we
go he said he's a rookie at a notre dame
a tight end a run blocking guy rod that
you will fall in love with almost a
george kittle i mean he'll take somebody
25 yards into the stands and then take
him into the locker room and sit on
bound right by their locker that's how
he blocks people in the run game so he's
somebody i'm really excited about i
think these pieces under coach rule are
going to go be something are they ready
to beat the best in the nfl yet maybe
not but i really do think they got a
good team forming down there in carolina
yeah man i think so too i mean they got
good leadership on the defensive side of
the ball a lot of really good young
players and they're just going to keep
getting better and one thing about matt
rule he's going to keep pushing those
guys he's not going to let those guys
ever get comfortable i i think he's
doing a terrific job with with the
panthers
let's get to your second turn the page
it's another one where you just gave me
a name which is kind of exciting i like
how you're doing this now because i
don't know which way you're going to go
marshawn lattimore is the name you gave
what page does he need to turn
he got beat for a touchdown by um saquon
barkley and he's out there he's a
hundred million dollar cornerback and
you got a running back and you're
one-on-one and he cheats he thinks that
saquon barkley can't catch the ball and
he tries to cheat on the stop route and
look at this you can't do that you're a
100 million dollar quarterback against a
running back you have to show him
respect and that's my thing right there
that's all i wanted to say marshawn
lattimore when you're out there with
those running backs never take it for
granted he thought he could just go and
steal him an interception end up costing
his team the game
he needs to take rod if you were a head
i'm just curious now uh you got me
curious like
a would you pay a cornerback a hundred
million dollars or you know would you be
more likely to pay a at this point they
have a wide receiver making 100 million
and thomas michael thomas and they have
a cornerback making 100 million almost
in lattimore
which of those two positions would you
pay or would you pay two of them like
the saints have now done
you said quarterback
cornerback
wide receiver
and wide receiver because michael
johnson is making 100 plus too
that's easy i'm never ever ever paying a
wide receiver 100 million dollars never
never i'd rather test that in my
offensive line i'm invested in that in
my offensive line or my defensive line
up front but you can find good really
good wide receivers whether it's through
the draft some veteran players or some
young guys but i have to have a great
offensive line and a defensive front
that's where i'm spending my money
there's one more thing we agree on let's
get to this third one the denver broncos
first loss of the year maybe a bigger
loss teddy bridgewater with the
concussion with the injury he's dealing
with how do they turn the page there in
denver
well they're gonna have to they're gonna
have to really rely on that run game
with javonte williams and they don't
have to rely on that defense they have a
lot of money they spent in the secondary
and have a really good secondary but
they're gonna have to lean on that
defense and those pass rushers von
miller because without with without
teddy and teddy's a guy that they truly
believe in he's accurate
he's accurate he makes a lot of smart
decisions and he's a guy that they truly
believed in and when he got hurt
locke came in and he just he just he
just didn't look like he had a
confidence but teddy's a guy that they
truly believe in and when you believe in
a guy you have to make sure that you
protect teddy teddy has a history of
injuries so you can't allow him to take
a bunch of hits whether it's six-man
protection seven-man protection you got
to protect your quarterback
how good do you think denver is right
now i just just when you look at them
from from kind of 30 000 feet looking at
this team and let's assume that at some
point teddy bridgewater will be able to
come back from this concussion he may
miss a week may miss two weeks we don't
know the specifics of it if teddy
bridgewater comes back how far can the
denver broncos go with fangio coaching
this defense and with teddy bridgewater
running this offense
if they're healthy on the defensive side
of the ball and play on a level that
they should play on and if teddy's
healthy along with cortland sutton and
those guys patrick
and the run game with javonte williams
and no offense no offense is a guy a kid
that i just absolutely love every time i
see him play he looks like a faster
younger version of rob gronkowski but i
think this team could definitely take
the seventh spot in the afc as far as
the playoffs is concerned
wow that's saying something right there
that's a long way from where they were
with drew lock playing quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports